president biden getting ready to smear
half the country as a bunch of
semi-fascists for his soul of the nation
speech subjecting americans to another
rambling lecture on how evil maga
republicans are the white house giving
us a preview by calling conservative
voters an extremist threat to our
democracy and adding this today
we understand we hit a nerve we get that
we understand that they're trying to
hide and
we understand that ultra maga office
holders
want to play games here and dodge
accountability for their extreme
proposals and actions but they're just
telling on themselves we're talking
about
agenda that is not popular we're talking
about agendas that is incredibly extreme
we're talking about an agenda that is
not in line where majority of americans
are when we talk about the extremism
we're talking about a very small
peace
component of
of the american public
very small but basically the crux of
their speech
anyway republicans planning a pre-buddle
to the speech by highlighting democrats
record on crime and inflation here's
kevin mccarthy the problem with joe
biden is he does not understand the soul
of america the tens of millions of
hard-working law-abiding citizens that
he vilifies they want a stronger safer
more prosperous america and all he does
is vilify him to distract from the
disasters and no plan he has to save
america from where we are today
all right brian i want to go to you
first remember this is not fox and
friends so stay focused
so he's calling this is he's calling it
the soul of a nation right so i guess
this isn't going to be about policies
like crime war inflation he's going to
go after this amorphous threat right a
large looming kind of quasi-terror group
that perhaps he could pin all of the
country's problems on i know people have
different ways of motivating people some
get in your face some do through praise
others do it through stairs how about
berating people and in terms of just
dredging up their soul it's unbelievable
that he is going to do this and i think
most networks are going to avoid this
because it's it's a total campaign
speech which he's going to do in prime
time so i just think that this one
thing's very interesting he has every
facet of the government working playing
politics i always thought the press
secretary was told to stay out of it if
they do get into it they get rebuked
right away she's actually reading from
her notes she never usually does that uh
but um about all these negative things
like for example i mean if you're kevin
mccarthy just point out listen mag if
you want to be labeling me magga okay
because i'm for uh rewriting trade deals
that bring manufacturing back to the
country i'm for a strong defense i'm for
building a wall and having security and
if countries breach our security they're
going to be tariffed and they're going
to be hit i'm for giving parents control
of the classroom or a say in the
classroom i'm not for mandating of
vaccines but i'm for
providing the best i can the information
to move forward i will not for locking
you down and preventing you from working
i am not going to fire you that's the
mega republican i think they just want
to label anybody uh everybody that is a
republican someone who's in the capital
january 6th there you go you know dana
it's kind of it's got to be hard for joe
to reconcile the fact that he's he
claims he's a staunch rep catholic yet
he believes that the the roe v wade
turnover is somehow a threat to the soul
of america hasn't he sold his soul to
the pro-abortion lobby how can he talk
about the soul of america well it is
interesting that word soul isn't it um
yes so he
the position that he used to have would
have been safe legal rare right
but now the democratic position is
actually extremely extreme which is uh a
lot legal abortion up until the point of
death and that is not where the country
is on that
i think something that's been lost here
is that in the mississippi dis case that
was decided by the supreme court that
was a 15-week
limit
and that's kind of like where europe is
it's where most the country is and for
some reason conservatives have walked
away from talking about this argument
and this is actually something that they
could press forward but on the broader
picture here
i think most republicans will probably
ignore this for the most part or hit it
and then move on to things that people
really care about since
biden announced the student loan uh
announcement one of the polls shows he
went down seven points
drive home on all of the issues that you
know people care about do not allow this
crazy distraction to get you off track
and you could ask the question what in
your life
where government touches it what in your
life is better today than it was two
years ago name something and most people
wouldn't i don't know what they would
say jessica's probably has a great
answer to that but i was thinking about
it today um
but i also do
just comment on the press secretary
thing but so that position you are
the spokesperson for all of america
or also you have to advocate for the
president of the united states but one
of the things is there is a democratic
national committee that committee has a
spokesperson and that spokesperson could
go ahead and do this they can't the
white house is apparently really upset
that anyone is calling this a campaign
event they're in a campaign message but
it's clearly a trial balloon for what
they're going to run on but it's the
exact same thing that they ran on in
2020 which is against donald trump and
people who supported him right and it's
like a it's also like a pre
a precursor or for for another january
6th
hearing in in october that's coming up
so it's basically the introduction to
the next season of their miniseries
insurrection judge is this a wide wise
strategy to target a category of
citizens rather than just individual
leaders you know as a semi-fascist i
find it offensive
well you want to carry it for all of us
we appreciate that
yes um you know here's the thing that i
i think is so ironic that he's doing
this you know in philadelphia in uh
independence park i mean you know like
the birthplace of of a lot of um the
birthplace of american government that
kind of thing it represents it but it's
really an indictment this is an
indictment of everyone who didn't vote
for joe biden because 73 million people
voted for donald trump this is all about
bringing donald trump back into the
middle of things when the election isn't
about donald trump it's not about donald
trump he's not running as far as i know
or anyone else he's not on the ballot
but they are so afraid of dealing with
their losses and the problems that we
are facing in this country that we've
got to have a new boogeyman we're going
to make it the mega people they're
semi-fascists and anyone who's a student
of history understands that this does
not end well that when you start
segregating people and accusing them of
being something that is so negative so
hateful that it then spins into a
democrat strategist saying these
semi-fascists mirror nazi germany and
mussolini i mean we can all see where
this is going to go hate is hate hate
leads to violence and that leads to
retaliation he's failed to unify the
country and now he's dividing it even
more
and i think that
it was a great article in the wall
street journal it said once biden
blurted out semi-fascist he pretty much
opened the door to debating whether or
not he is a semi-socialist and where
he's taking america and i think that
that is an incredibly important point
but but given that both sides think that
democracy is in danger of collapse i
think the most important thing that the
republicans can do right now is have a
message he's calling republicans names
he's calling all of us deplorables worse
than deplorables and it's about time the
republicans whether it's mccarthy or
anyone else got a lock on what
republicans stand for
well i think that about covers it so
coming up
i'm kidding jessica i just assume you
agreed with everything we had to say
especially what the judge just put out
yeah yeah i mean obviously this this
becomes this this back and forth thing
like oh fascist a socialist fascist but
he didn't speak up when there was crime
going on for a long time
and
it's just strange that the cons like
there's there was a consistent nightly
riot that he was silent about
it's obviously a political
uh theatrical device to go after january
6. it's one day anomaly everybody hated
it
you know
well he's also he's in pennsylvania
which is an important swing state and
john federman and dr oz are in this
increasingly tighter race right
batterman had a bit of a bigger lead
we've seen a couple holes now that it
might be tightening up there it it's
okay for things that the president is
doing to be linked to the campaign he
wants democrats to win and he wants to
be out there to make sure that you know
they have as much fodder to go and
campaign with as possible i have no
objection to that and i don't think the
white house should fight that
characterization
but
i don't think that belittling the fact
that now for years and i know this
because it's been an insult personally
lobbed at me over and over where
republicans do paint the democratic
party as socialist they talk about
whether you're a democratic socialist or
a socialist if they're in charge the
country is going to turn into venezuela
and you look at famed communists and
socialists throughout time now stalin
castro those guys are pretty bad too and
i get it that fascism because people
think of hitler hits a particular note
and it does for me as well and maybe
it's not a good thing to have these
names floating around in the ether
whatsoever but it is important to call a
spade a spade and former president trump
who by the way the reason we're talking
about him is because he won't stop
talking he won't get off true
socialism they didn't raise his house
they actually did it
um
the execution of a search warrant it is
not a raid and
earlier wait a minute when i sent my
guys out with guns
and with the ability to break down doors
and blow up and hold on
at 6 30 in the morning and make him
stand outside in his panties right he
wasn't even there when this happened
i don't think he wears panties but
trump called earlier this week for the
overturning of the 2020 election and to
be declared the quote rightful win
you get it but that's just to say to me
we get it when everyone else we know
what yeah but what you're doing is
you're you're you're making that
argument
smearing a large group of people because
of one day and i'm asking where were you
guys when people's buildings were being
burned down when dozens of people were
killed when neighborhoods were believing
you guys didn't say a damn thing because
it was your side doing it so enough of
this stuff about january 6. everybody
there's nobody on the right that thinks
that's a good thing january 6 has not
come out of my mouth and you know until
you said it and you know who does think
it's an okay thing donald trump who
called into newsmax today and he said
that he's helping out people who
participated in january 6 paying their
lawyers
i read it on twitter i did not watch
so
let's be fair here we are
but jessica everything you said is
perfect for democrats because it's about
donald trump there's nothing about
donald trump in the news until they
raided his house yeah or else he would
just be doing an interview here and then
talking about it
and the biggest decision was whether he
was going to run or not there you go
that was lively
lively
up next liberal lockdowns are racing two
decades worth of education progress and
somehow the bite administration finds a
way to blame trump jessica
i want to brian kilmeade i want you do
me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now